two double murders in Omaha Nebraska
over five years made residents worry
that a killer was picking random targets
a school boy 11 years old a housekeeper
a doctor and his wife were the victims
on tomorrow's 48 hours Jim Axelrod
reports on the clues that connected the
deaths to a well known hospital from the
beginning this was strange that happened
in Dundee the heart of a lot it was
March 13 2008 11 year-old Thomas Hunter
was captured on this school bus video
arriving home Thomas was a waif of a kid
smart kid loved science math the hunters
housekeeper surely Sherman was waiting
for him grandma
gentle soul Todd Cooper is the court
reporter for the Omaha world-herald
it's the mundane world of after school
and then it's just shattered by a
monster you remember getting the call I
do
Omaha police detective Derek Moyes was
one of the first on scene I remember
walking in their front door there's a
little boy lying face down in a very
large pool of blood you get to the back
door you see this lady who had very
evidently been pushed down to the ground
and attacked no DNA no motive no
apparent suspects but one neighbor
spotted an unfamiliar car and caught a
glimpse of the driver then five years
later and just a few miles away came a
break but in the form of another
horrific tragedy a prominent doctor and
his wife murdered Roger Brumback devoted
portions of his medical career to
childhood disease Mary burnback could
not have had an enemy in the world it's
Scott and I had a real definitive moment
after we
that house I've seen these things before
when had the last time been that you had
seen stabbings like that was 2008 with
Thomas and Shirley and there was another
connection Creighton University Medical
Center dr. Roger Brumback was chairman
of the pathology department his close
professional colleague Tom Hunter's
father dr. bill hunter someone was
targeting doctors lightbulb must have
gone off fluid very brightly it wasn't
long before doctor Anthony Garcia's name
came up a former Creighton Medical
Center resident who had been fired by
doctors hunter and Brumback did your son
kill Tommy Hunter Shirlee Sherman Roger
and Mary Brumback I don't know if it did
it's a totally different person that
they're talking about mmm Jim Alex Roy
joins us at the table um Jim it's a
homicide listen is never good but it
certainly seems more egregious and more
painful when it's a child involved a lot
of emotion in this story there were
pictures that were so difficult for me
to look at now there were interviews
there's a motion at every turn in this
story you don't see homicide detectives
cry very often we see a motion there you
see obviously an 11-year old boy the
emotion there the mother of the suspect
sat for an interview that was among the
most painful things I've ever had a
watch as she was sort of wrestling with
the notion that maybe her son was a
killer this is an hour full of emotion
Wow and they think dr. Garcia had the
motivation well it was a revenge story
it was a cold case for five years
because they were looking at who could
have killed an 11 year old boy I may be
the target was his father Jim thank you
thank you very much
you can watch Jim Axelrod's full story
it's called resident evil on 48 hours
that's tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central
here on CBS